que je défends ici l'avendement de mon
collègue Michel Savin qui considère à
juste titre qu'il est incompréhensible
que les adolescents puissent pratiquer
une activité sportive au collège ou au
lycée en EPS ou bien lors de leurs
activités réalisées avec l'UNSS et que
les mêmes pratiques dans le cadre
associatif souvent dans les mêmes lieux
lorsqu'on interdites s'ils ne présente
pas de pas sanitaire c'est amendement
est donc une mesure de bon sens qui vise
à permettre aux mineurs de continuer à
pratiquer une activité physique et
sportive au sein d'une association
sportive ou d'un club sans avoir à
présenter le Pass la pratique sportive
est un élément majeur pour la santé
publique de nos concitoyens la crise
sanitaire a profondément affecté la
pratique des Français notamment des plus
jeunes le renforcement de la sédentarité
est un véritable problème de santé
publique il convient de combattre
vivement par ailleurs les retours
concernant les inscriptions dans les
associations sportives en ce début
d'année montrent que les mineurs de 12 à
18 ans se sont éloignés de la pratique
quand le retour en club des moins de 12
ans est extrêmement dynamique